[Music]
in florida
donald trump fans are feeling confident
sleepy joe about to get destroyed
by the dawn by the dawn danny
but the polls are tight here and in a
last-minute scramble for votes
trump and biden faced off in florida
we are going to win florida we are going
to win four
more years in the white house florida
goes blue
it's over at clashing rallies they told
the faithful
why they're the best man for the job in
a state of millions which in the past
has been won by a few hundred votes do
you feel that people sometimes treat
you negatively when you say you support
trump oh yeah i do what happened
i just get weird looks a lot of people
my age say
not nice things and they just say
mean stuff and they ask why do you like
a racist and they don't ever
say why he's racist they just make
assumptions if joe biden wants to crush
donald trump's hopes in one place then
florida is
it and the closer we get to election day
the tenser it gets
a few miles away donna and beth are on
the trail for biden
we're trying to save our democracy if
you truly feel that that
is what's on the line what sort of
tensions are you seeing how's it playing
out
a lot of use of the f-bomb especially
and being called baby killer that's
that's that's a key one for
uh the other side and then uh
the physically getting into our space
like
waving their banners
have you ever seen america this divided
no not this oh no
no and i'm gonna tell you i'm 73 years
old
and i have never seen america in this
battery
for some the fight for florida has
become a bitter grudge match
the sunshine state is in for a stormy
time
siobhan robbins sky news florida